normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government let's
jump into the first story we have this
from Fox Business the context is
important Harvard president's handling
of anti-Semitism has cost a school more
than 1 billion according to Bill Amman
billionaire investor and influential
Harvard Alum Bill Amman continued his
push for his Alma moer to terminate
president Claude Dean gay over the
weekend claiming her handling of
anti-Semitism on campus since the
October 7th terror attack by Hamas on is
has cost the university more than a
billion dollars in donations in a letter
to Harvard's governing board of
directors posted on the social media
platform X on Sunday Amman argued gay
quote has done more damage to the
reputation of the institution than any
other individual in its nearly 500e
history going through a Litany of
criticisms over her leadership which he
says has contributed to Major donor
withdrawals significant gifts that uh
with withdrawing significant GI gifts
that are adding up here's what's
important let's break all this down
because the the article themselves don't
give you this context us today says
Harvard president Claude Dean gay to
remain University leaders of Firm
support this is somebody who right now
and we'll get into all the details has
been exposed as a plagiarist who should
not be in this position who does not
have the Merit the skill the
capabilities many people are saying
she's clearly A diversity hire this is
an individual that has failed in regards
to the hearing before Congress has
resulted in a loss of over a billion
dollars by any metric this person should
be fired yeah they will not fire her and
why because the only actual metric
Harvard cares about are you woke are you
a member of our religion and if you are
nothing else matters while the rest of
us look to Harvard and think it's some
higher education institution one of the
best it's not it's a church a church of
the woke and so the actual job
description for this woman is to be a
woke prostit prostit her so when she's
faced with mounting criticism the board
of directors and all these other people
say okay what are they criticizing her
about oh she's costing us money she's
engaged in a plagiarism Scandal they
actually covered up a major Scandal
we'll get into that in a bit and then
they go okay but that's not her job
description is she advancing diversity
equity and inclusion yes she's fine yeah
um it's and it's remarkable to see this
happening harv still has $50 billion in
their endowment so I don't think they're
hurting any anyway at all um but it's
it's it's absolutely incredible to watch
this play out in real time and wonder
what is the purpose of this University
right um there was another study that
came out today that Yale the majority of
the students at Yale all got A's last
semester you say well if everyone gets
A's these these universities don't
really seem to have any sort of academic
purpose I like that you're liken them to
a church that's the best way to put
themoney and like a church like if
you're parents a memb as you become a
member I would say they're more like a
hedge fund with a indoctrination Center
or even just a just a factory that
produces the woke mind virus but it's
it's interesting to see them kind of eat
their own eat themselves and attack
themselves on this very divisive issue
that is Israel when for many years now
they were being very discriminatory they
were being very racist they were
violating the civil rights of
individuals because of the way that they
were born and everyone was okay with
that now that we have the conflict in
Israel people are like okay now we got
to really have to deal with this issue
which uh which I find very peculiar at
this specific I find it peculiar that
I'll take it no go ahead no if if you
replaced Israel or anti-semite with any
other minority group and this was the
question facing the University president
would be a different story can you have
call for genocide against trans members
on Harvard campus no if if she did not
stand up if she didn't lie down in in in
in solidarity with a D in on the quad if
she didn't forcefully condemn this
before she would have been fired within
seconds but you can for white people
that are technically a minority on on
the world's
and then that's that's totally okay
that's totally fine but but then Bill
Amman actually calls them out for this
too there are a lot of people that are
like oh these these wealthy billionaires
didn't say anything when these
universities were discriminating against
white people and conservatives but now
that it's the Jews they're coming out
and no these billionaires actually are
coming on saying like we didn't realize
and you know what I'll take it I'll take
it look not everybody cares about what
you care about and there's a guy who's
dumping tons of money to University not
paying attention then it affects
something he cares about Israel I'm not
get mad at that I'm going to say welcome
to the fight thank you for finally
paying attention and calling this out
this is what made you this is what
impacted you impacted you okay well take
a look at what everyone else is
complaining about oh we agree awesome
let's win yeah yeah the that was uh to
your point Tim I was listening last
night you guys talk about uh about Bud
Light and that's another example when
you have people that are looking that
are that have have noticed that there is
a problem that you have been making no
about right you don't you don't attack
them and say oh you know now you know
and push them away you welcome them into
the fold so that way you have more
people on your side because the whole
point of the culture war is not to get
rid of the people that disagree and this
was something that Jordan Peterson made
this point about uh conservatives the
way that the the left had been treating
conservatives what are you going to do
with all the with all the Donald Trump
voters if you if you if beat you know
Donald Trump they're still Americans and
that's a that's something that we have
here in the US most of the division in
my opinion has been driven by the
ideological left pumping out
ideologically motivated people and they
have lied to your average Democrat your
average left left leaning liberal person
so they're still right leaning because
Liberals are kind of right leaning the
left is actually a totally different
philosophy so your average left-leaning
liberal has been lied to to and and has
been tricked into believing that woke is
the continuation of the Civil Rights
Movement which it is not is a totally
different tradition it's the exact
opposite of that transition as it
promotes discrimination against
individuals for the way that they were
born sorry one 100% absolutely yes and
and they're they're waking up to that
and we need to welcome that welcome them
back into the America loving liberal
society that we all are looking to back
to what we talk about all the time we
talk about we want to get rid of the
woke we want to get rid of all this bad
ideology and now is a great opportunity
to bring people back into the American
mindset where America is not always bad
and that it's not always just dump on
the liberal mindset Dave pornoy
announced he will not hire anybody from
Harvard MIT or upen until these people
are fired he then said good I think he's
he's pulled back on upen because they
did have the board member and the
president resign but he specifically
called her out and was like I'm not
going to hire anybody your degree is
worthless anybody who currently works
for me he was asked did you have people
applying he's like well I have people
who work here now but they're
grandfathered in anybody else you I will
not hire you because that degree James
Lindsay was making a very similar
argument saying only then when people
stop hiring these people is when we
could have a big cultural difference
here because that degree won't matter
anymore that Prestige won't mean
anything anymore because they actually
just shot themselves in the foot now
there is a lot of degrees of hyp
especially when it comes to saying yeah
you can hate on this group you can't ha
on this group oh now we're in trouble
for hating on this group but but still I
want to go back a little bit here
there's there's a lot of other
individuals like Cassandra McDonald
making the argument here hey we should
also be careful because we still want to
protect freedom of speech what do you
guys make of the argument here saying
hey uh whatever these policies are I
don't care freedom of speech still
should be protected here is this freedom
of speech and should it be it it be
protected Dave ptoy was asked about
their stance and he said no you should
not be allowed to call for the genocide
of a group of people that's where you're
getting into harm and violence etc etc I
disagree with him I agree with his
position that these people are
hypocrites they're Liars they're
cheaters they're thieves and you should
not hire people who are coming from
these universities and I I I I will say
that to whatever extent I can if you got
Harvard on your resume I'm throwing in
the trash yeah you know it's it's not
like we're hiring you know like crazy or
anything like that contractors whatever
I'm I'm I'm I'm avoiding all of that
these are these are corrupt institutions
I suppose it depends on how long ago you
were there or whatever but uh no I
actually I agree with what each and
every one of these individuals said to a
certain degree they said the
Constitution the right of the
individuals to have their opinion if
it's getting to the point where you're
harassing an individual that breaks the
rules I completely agree with that what
I don't agree with is that these people
are lying and spitting in our faces they
scream no pronouns you have to use the
you have to use our pronouns they scream
no fat phobia they will ban you from
campus they will shut your speech down
and then the moment it comes to a call
for genocide of the Jews they all of a
sudden say oh the Constitution I'm like
you are right the Constitution now screw
yourself I'm not defending you when are
you going to make a fat phobia shirt
because fat phobic lives matter too fat
fat lives matter too I don't know what
the what we I have a different point of
view I
have the exact opposite perspective uh
I'm joking we might get in trouble here
on YouTube if I express it it gets it
complicated it gets complicated because
the first amendment clearly says
Congress shall make no law right Harvard
is a private institution it has its own
laws and that's why the congresswoman
Alise stonic asked a very good question
she didn't say it is a violation of free
speech she said is it a violation of
your code of of ethics and as a private
institution it can make its own laws and
Harvard as a private institution saying
calling for violence violates our code
of e ethics well when you say antifa
from the The River To The Sea you're
calling for violence so that's why it
was really like connect the dots
congresswoman stepanic set her up
perfectly to give a very good answer
that was clear all she did was unravel
this cluster disaster of of wokeness
this is all awesome it was brilliant all
of this the story everything this is
this is why it's the lead ladies and
gentlemen yeah when Harvard this morning
when when the news broke that they said
unequivocally we will not fire this
woman I was like thank you yeah that's
the message we want to share with
everybody they are they they lie they
are hateful they are racist they are
plagiarists your kids going to these
schools will not be better off they will
be manipulated indoctrinated and when it
when when proof was there that this
person should not have this job they
said screw off yeah remember when the
NAACP sent out an announcement saying
that no African-Americans should go to
Florida right they should just boycott
of Florida someone else just an LGBT
group just did that the other day I saw
it on Twitter same exact they're raising
money to get people out who are are gay
or trans out of
Florida will will the Anti-Defamation
League will will Abe foxman will one of
these Jewish groups start an an actual
boycott of Harvard to say we call on all
Jews to boycott Harvard because clearly
it is a danger I mean that was the
naacp's argument for Florida you are
endangering yourself if you go to this
state well clearly if you're Jewish
you're endangering yourself if you go to
Harvard I got to be honest I'm not big
on wanting to hire college graduates as
it is so I don't care if it's Harvard I
go to college yeah I don't care if it's
Harvard or go to the Sciences you know
if if you're hire a college graduate
that went to one of the hard Sciences or
that studied something real but if
you're just hiring someone they still
teach them woke trash even in the yeah
they have to I understand that but that
you know that's something that we're
going to have that's something that
actually has to be addressed by culture
though because cuz you get people that
go and they study them they'll major in
something and they'll minor in some kind
of woke thing and so that they're laying
like a groundwork or or at least a
tertiary knowledge of the of the the ins
and outs of the woke ideology and that's
something that has to be changed by you
know by by the nightly uh comedy shows
the you know late night shows not
reinforcing that stuff will do a lot
well a lot of the wok up has a lot to do
with the revisioning of capitalism it
also goes all the way back to David
Rockefeller pushing a whole bunch of
huge money into higher institutions of
learning that he was able to influence
that of course undermines the very kind
of capitalism that put him in the
position of power that he was in that of
course he was uh manipulating and
abusing for his own personal benefit so
this has roots going back many many
years ago and now we're seeing the kind
of formation of it and it kind of just
falling on its face right now with this
Harvard kind of controversy as now we
are finally being exposed to the true
kind of hatred and nature of this
socialistic leftist brainwashing
campaign that now finally is being
called out there's one thing I want you
mentioned James James Lindsay a little
while ago and we just had him on the
show that's why I we just had a
conversation I'm a huge fan and I've
mentioned him a lot and I I'm going to
mention him again because right now the
best thing about them allowing the
president to stay uh stay at Harvard is
it it really shines a light on the fact
that we are living in the logic of
Herbert Mark Hugh's repressive tolerance
the the argument made in that in that
piece is that it's okay to do whatever
you want if you're on the left and the
right must be suppressed at even the
level of thinking right-wing thoughts
and to the left at least in college on
college campuses now everyone that's not
left of them is the right and must be
censored and has to be shut down so it's
it's good to like I'm with Tim I think
this is good that that that they're
standing behind her it's good that she's
not stepping down it's good that Harvard
is doing this so that way it shines a
light on it so that way the American
people can see all right we do have a
real problem in the United States now
let's focus on MIT that also has
Intelligence Agency connections and
let's expose that whole larger problem
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net